[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera Y esto es
aquí América el magazín de France 24
para revisar en profundidad las noticias
y las historias de nuestro continente y
esto es lo que veremos hoy el
expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump admitió tener en su residencia
privada documentos clasificados según un
audio previamente el favorito para
convertirse en el candidato republicano
que se enfrente al demócrata Joe biden
en las elecciones presidenciales de 2024
ha negado a haber actuado mal
y vamos a Florida que desde el primero
de julio tiene más de 200 leyes
impulsadas por ron the santis quien
desafió a Trump por la nominación
republicana son precisamente medidas
conservadoras que afectan varios ámbitos
desde la educación sexual el permiso
para aportar armas ocultas hasta la
migración
la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro lanzó un operativo contra
la violencia que emula las
controvertidas políticas de su vecino
nayib bukele en El Salvador
y vamos de inmediato a Estados Unidos
para nuestra historia principal el
expresidente Donald Trump admitió en un
audio grabado en junio de 2021 seis
meses después de haber abandonado la
casa blanca que sí tiene documentos
clasificados en su residencia Privada de
Nueva Jersey según las leyes
estadounidenses todos los documentos
tienen que ser entregados a la oficina
de archivos nacionales al final de un
mandato y toda persona que
intencionalmente oculte o destruya
documentos oficiales podría ser multada
encarcelada e inhabilitada Para ocupar
cargos públicos esta intencionalidad al
parecer queda en evidencia en el audio
que fue divulgado por la cadena 100 en y
el New York Times escuchemos
lo hicieron los militares que me lo
dieron creo que probablemente podamos no
no lo sé tendríamos que ver tendríamos
que intentar
desclasificarlo verá como presidente
podría haberlo desclasificado ahora no
puedo pero no es interesante es genial
imputado por este caso convirtiéndose en
el primer expresidente en recibir cargos
federales la fiscalía general considera
que violó la ley no solo al tomar los
documentos secretos tanto a esa
residencia de Pet minster en Nueva
Jersey sino a la del mar al lago también
en Florida y además que obstruyó la
investigación al respecto los 37 cargos
federales se dividen así
[Música]
31 por retención deliberada de
información de seguridad nacional que
podría traerle una pena de 10 años de
cárcel un cargo de Conspiración para
obstruir a la justicia que le daría
hasta 20 años uno de retención de
documentos que le daría otros 20 años
uno más por ocultar un documento o
registro que tiene una pena de hasta 20
años otro cargo por ocultar un documento
en una investigación Federal con una
pena de hasta 20 años
uno por concierto para ocultar
documentos que le daría hasta cinco años
y otro por declaraciones falsas con una
pena de hasta cinco años esto
precisamente por haber negado que sabía
que tenía los documentos clasificados
esta semana el expresidente repitió que
se trata de una investigación con
motivos políticos
pero el paso más importante realmente
drenar el Pantano es la militarización
del departamento de justicia y el abuso
de los mecanismos de cumplimiento de la
ley para detener el discernimiento
político
como ustedes saben hace dos semanas el
retorcido de Joe biden ordenó que su
principal oponente político fuera
arrestado Oh Quién es él o soy yo en
plena mitad de la campaña presidencial
que su oponente está ganando por mucho
piensen en eso eso no estaba en el
libreto porque el público Es realmente
inteligente mis números subieron
Pero al final no están persiguiéndome a
mí al final están persiguiendo los a
ustedes yo estoy en su camino correcto
sabemos eso no hay dudas de que se están
desesperando realmente Mientras nos ven
liderando con estos márgenes que Muy
pocas personas han visto antes
a primera vista podría creerse que el
hecho de que Trump haya sido imputado
con cargos federales Podría tener
impacto en su carrera por la reelección
por el expresidente tiene razón es el
favorito en la contienda por la
aspiración republicana recordemos que el
candidato republicano se elige a través
de una serie de primarias y caucus
asambleas partidistas estatales Incluso
si Trump es condenado Por alguno de los
cargos que se le imputa no estaría
impedido para llegar a la casa blanca
pues la Constitución de Estados Unidos
estipula solamente tres requisitos para
quienes desean aspirar a la presidencia
el primero es que haya nacido en Estados
Unidos el segundo que haya vivido en el
país al menos 14 años y el tercero es
que tenga 35 años o más es decir no está
estipulado que una persona procesada o
incluso condenada no puede aspirar a la
presidencia no obstante son varios los
republicanos que esperan que los
procesos contra Trump tengan impacto en
la opinión de los votantes y lo han
desafiado Uno de ellos es el gobernador
de Florida Run de santis que justamente
en medio de esta campaña promulgó más de
200 leyes de corte conservador en
materia de Educación los profesores ya
no podrán preguntar a los estudiantes
cuáles son sus pronombres preferidos ni
respetarán su identidad de género
también se prohíbe la enseñanza sobre el
ciclo menstrual y usar fondos públicos
para iniciativas de diversidad se
elimina además la exigencia de un
permiso al porte oculto de armas y las
empresas privadas con más de 25
empleados deberán utilizar Every para
demostrar la elegibilidad legal de los
trabajadores el corresponsal de France
24 en Miami Antonio el chinos cuenta más
hace más de 20 años que Berta llegó a
Estados Unidos desde Nicaragua entró con
una visa de turista para estar 90 días y
no volvió a salir ya lo tenía planeado
quería una vida mejor desde entonces ha
estado trabajando como empleada
doméstica porque no tiene papeles para
vivir legalmente saber que nos vamos al
trabajo y no sabemos si vamos a regresar
a casa son tantas situaciones que cada
persona indocumentada pasa en este país
mientras pasan los días y no tenés un
documento de trabajo
ahora Berta vive atemorizada por la
nueva ley de Florida contra la migración
irregular impulsada por el gobernador
ron de santis se contemplan penas de
hasta 15 años de prisión a quienes
transporten indocumentados al Estado
imponen multas de mil dólares diarios a
quienes contratenían documentados e
invaliden todas las tarjetas de
identificación salvo la de Florida ella
no puede conducir y se arriesga a ser
arrestada hay mucho temor en la
comunidad y somos nosotros quienes
estamos haciendo el trabajo que los
ciudadanos no quieren hacer
la nueva ley ha puesto contra las
cuerdas a sectores como el campo o la
construcción donde se estima que trabaja
más del 40% de los indocumentados por
eso Muchos ya están pensando Incluso en
cerrar su negocio ante la previsible
falta de personal si nos afecta porque
Incluso si es un documentados en los van
yo acá Tengo pensado en cerrar varias
semanas o dos o tres semanas Porque no
tenemos mano de obra algunos analistas
opinan que esta legislación solo es una
estrategia política de The santis para
su carrera presidencial de 2024 por el
partido republicano Aunque el gobierno
de Florida se defiende dice que el
objetivo de la ley es luchar contra el
tráfico humano se enriquecen todos estos
coyotes mexicanos
los carteles de la droga los utilizan
como transporte Mientras tanto la
comunidad migrante sin papeles está en
la incertidumbre sin saber cómo se
aplicará realmente esta medida pero
aseguran que lucharán hasta el final y
prometen llevar la ley ante la justicia
y seguimos en Estados Unidos pero
cambiamos de tema 109 mil personas
murieron en 2022 por sobredosis por lo
que la administración de Joe biden ha
decidido tomar medidas para
contrarrestar las cifras y empezar a
tratar el tema como un asunto de salud
pública la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos la fda por sus siglas en
inglés permite ahora la venta de
naloxona sin prescripción médica se
trata de un medicamento que frena el
efecto de las drogas en caso de una
sobredosis la corresponsal de France 24
en Nueva York mamen sala habló con una
persona que sobrevivió dos veces a una
sobredosis gracias a ese medicamento
stefen ha sobrevivido a dos sobredosis
de fentanilo gracias al analoxona ahora
viene semanalmente a este centro social
y ayuda a jóvenes que tratan de
abandonar las drogas
y comparte con ellos los consejos que le
ayudaron a superar su adicción tienes
que querer esto entiendes creer en ti
mismo en la recuperación
sí creer en ti mismo a veces cuando
somos adictos activos nuestra autoestima
cae Así que una vez que te recuperas es
solo recuperarte porque nadie tiene la
medicina exacta construyes de nuevo esa
autoestima
Stephen de 63 años ha pasado más de 30
en prisión y le han disparado hasta en
nueve ocasiones sin embargo nada le ha
asustado más que ver la muerte de cerca
cuando sufrió su última sobredosis
perdí la conciencia decían que empecé a
sangrar mucho y tuvieron que usar como
cuatro narcan para de vuelta
es el nombre comercial de la analoxona
la misma que administran a este joven de
17 años que acaba de sufrir una
sobredosis
es un antídoto nasal que detiene
temporalmente el efecto de las drogas
las autoridades sanitarias creen que
puede salvar miles de Vidas por eso a
partir de ahora las farmacias lo
venderán sin receta médica por 50
dólares
Esto es lo que revierte una dosis
alguien lo abre y es muy fácil de usar
por la nariz la manera de usarlo es que
lo pones dentro de la nariz de alguien Y
aprietas una vez y pones en el otro lado
y también aprietas otra vez en segundos
si alguien tiene una sobredosis de
opioides puedes revertirla
el arma perfecta para reducir el elevado
número de muertes por sobredosis que hay
en Estados Unidos Stephen le debe la
vida a la analoxona por eso coincide en
que esta nueva Norma supone un gran paso
y nos vamos a Honduras tras varios días
con varios episodios de violencia que
dejaron Al menos 20 fallecidos como una
masacre en un billar y múltiples
asesinatos así como un motín en una
prisión en las afueras de Tegucigalpa
que dejó a 46 reclusas muertas la
presidentación mara Castro lanzó una
ofensiva en contra de las pandillas que
emula la de su vecino de El Salvador
nayib bukele quien ha despertado
preocupación de organismos
internacionales por su concentración del
Poder y presuntas violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos la mandataria ordenó a
la policía militar tomar el control de
las prisiones y decretó el toque de
queda en Choloma y en San Pedro Sula y
desplegó una serie de operativos que
incluyen detenciones y allanamientos a
través de Twitter su esposo el depuesto
ex presidente Manuel Zelaya Quien cumple
funciones de secretario de seguridad
divulgó imágenes de hombres arrestados y
en ropa interior mientras son
custodiados por decenas de oficiales
Esto fue lo que dijeron la manda ria y
su esposo
la vida y la seguridad de los ciudadanos
y sus bienes la garantiza la
Constitución nuestra misión es derrotar
el crimen organizado que está en las
cárceles y vamos sobre los autores
intelectuales que operan desde afuera
dentro del plan de seguridad solución
contra el crimen y el estado de
excepción se inicia la operación candado
Valle de Sula dirigida presencialmente
por el ministro de seguridad general
Gustavo Sánchez acompañado por el
coronel Julio a Ruiz de la brigada 105 y
la Policía Militar del orden público la
cantante Madonna icono mundial del pop
aplazó las 84 fechas de su gira
celebrations con la que iba a conmemorar
sus 40 años de carrera tras enfermar de
una infección bacteriana
[Música]
su representante afirmó que se está
recuperando y que comunicará las nuevas
fechas cuando estén disponibles las
entradas para la gira de la ganadora de
un Grammy están prácticamente agotadas
Gracias por ver esta emisión de aquí
América en la producción estuvo Jennifer
Guevara por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla
Recuerden que pueden ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en la página web France
24.com Sigan viendo más en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]